what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard
and this is the channel where we talk
about all things data data science
statistics and programming so subscribe
for all kinds of content just like this
if you haven't already and hit the
notification bell so youtube notifies
you whenever i upload a video
this is another video in my r tutorial
series
and specifically it's part two in a
series of videos i'm doing on carrot
which is a one-stop shop for all of your
machine learning needs
so if you haven't seen part one yet i
highly recommend watching that one
before this one
the link will be up above in a card as
well as in the description of this video
but basically in part one we covered
some of the steps that are necessary
before you even
think about training models and things
like that
so some general formatting of the data
visualizing the distributions of
different variables by your response
variable
identifying near zero variance features
and we left off with pre-processing the
data
so things like imputing missing data one
hot encoding the data set
so that you have one nice consistent
format for these factor variables
and then normalizing all the variables
and so where we're going to pick off
in this part of the tutorial is applying
these same transformations to the test
set
because remember we started with
applying these transformations to the
training set
we need to do the exact same thing to
the test set so before we get started
here
hit the like button for the youtube
algorithm i'll have a link in the
description of the video to my patreon
account if you guys would be willing to
support me over that way
that would be massively appreciated and
as always this script is available on my
github repo
and that'll obviously be in the
description too so let's take a minute
to remember
exactly what's going on in the
pre-processing stages
so when we use this pre-process function
here we pass a method to it
and remember there's three things that
we want to do we want to impute
the missing data using a bagging
approach we want to use this dummy vares
function which is
essentially doing the exact same thing
to perform one hot encoding
that gets all of our factor variables
into the same general format
and then at the end we want to normalize
so
we want to transform our variables to a
0 1 scale
and that's where method equals range
comes into play
well the output when we run the
preprocess or the dummy vars
function the output of that is actually
the transformation
we can then apply that transformation to
our data
using the predict function so
all we did was just go through a similar
procedure three times
one for bag impute one for dummy vares
and one for uh method equals range
we did that three times and along the
way
the response variable class got dropped
so we had to add that back in well okay
we already have all these
transformations applied and we've
already
applied all of them to our training set
now all we have to do is apply the exact
same transformations to the test set
so if we just go one by one we use the
predict function
for this bag missing transformation
we've defined
that imputes our missing data pass in
the test set
we have a new test set object do the
same thing for the dummy model for the
one hot
encoding do the same thing for the range
model for the
normalization then along the way the
output turns into a matrix
we want data frames here so i'm going to
transform this back into a data frame
and then just like what happened in the
training set
the response variable got dropped so
we're going to add that back in
now just as one last step here it's
possible that the names get kind of
changed around and it's not consistently
applied
from the training set to the test set
that is the transformations can get
applied a little bit differently and the
names can get messed up
so it's helpful just to prevent future
errors down the road
just run this last line of code here to
make sure the names are the same
with that we're ready to rock and roll
now one final pre-processing step you
should be aware of
is how you go about removing low
information features
now a low information feature is not
necessarily the same thing as a zero
variance feature a zero variance feature
is a type of low information feature
but it's not the only kind and just as a
general rule
if you have a lot of useless
uninformative variables in your data set
it is going to harm your performance now
i'm going to show you an algorithmic way
that you can go about removing
uninformative variables
it's called recursive feature
elimination but as a general rule
i'd actually like to caution you away
from this approach just because
i like letting the domain expertise
handle
how you eliminate variables having said
that recursive feature elimination is a
pretty streamlined and algorithmic and
consistent way that you can go about
removing low information features so
we're going to cover it here even if
i'm not necessarily going to use it here
so at a high level
the basis for recursive feature
elimination is the fact that
several different methods out there
provide ways of ranking variables from
most to least
important for instance with linear
models you can use the absolute value of
the t
statistic random forest provides
variable importance ranking
so on and so forth there are several
other examples
so what we're going to do here is we're
going to build many models of
whatever machine learning method that we
want to use on the training set
and we start with an initial ranking of
these variables from most to least
important
now again we're going to use multiple
models
and at every step we're going to
iteratively recalculate the most
important variables it's just up front
we're going to have
priority to what variables have we found
to be the most important up front
we're going to use subsets of all the
available variables
and actually you can specify this up
front for instance i want to use
1 through 5 variables as well as 10 15
20. and now here's how we're going to
set this up
we're going to use this rfe control
function
and now this first argument here
functions
is going to allow us to determine what
type of method that we want to use
so if you go to the help documentation
you can see
how to specify this scroll down to the
bottom here where it specifies the
details
and it lays out that you can use lm
functions for linear models
rf functions for random forest tree bag
as well as nb functions where the nb
stands for
naive bayes but we're going to set this
up
and what it's going to output for us is
the most important variables
so this code does take a little bit of
time to run i want to give you fair
warning of that
but at the end it's going to output for
us the top five variables out of the
ones that were
uh iterated through we've got employment
duration
amount property real estate telephone
dot one
and age now like i said before i'm not
going to use this information
but there are certainly instances in
which doing an approach like this is
going to help you out
so it's just something to have on your
radar as a possible approach
all right now we're going to get into
the moment that everybody's been waiting
for
which is we're going to train our first
model using carrot
and we're going to do that using the
simply named train function
now i can't even begin to express to you
guys how powerful this function
is and how much it does just within one
single function so one of the arguments
to the train function
is this thing called tr control now
this takes in a training control object
we're going to see this later
but that training control object
controls for how we tune our
hyperparameters
within this same function we're also
going to cross validate the model and
select an
optimally performing model based on our
metric of choice
so extremely powerful function and we're
going to see it in action in a minute
here
and we're also going to return the
variable importance plot from one single
uh method what was kind of going on in
the back end when we did the recursive
feature elimination
but before we do that it's good to get
an idea of the full scope of models that
can be trained using carrot
now several of these are going to
require installation of separate
packages
but if you run the get model info
function and then just
call the names of that you get an idea
of just how many methods that we can
call
and as you see this is an absolutely
massive list
so there's a lot that we can do but
we're going to start with one of my
absolute favorite machine learning
methods which is the random forest
for our first time taking the train
function for a spin
i'm not going to do any kind of fancy
configuration to it whatsoever
i'm going to specify the bare minimum
configurations here
and then just let the train function
figure out the best way
it wants to train this model so on the
first line here i'm just going to set
the seed for reproducibility purposes
now to the train function i have to
specify the formula
remember class is our response variable
i want to use all the variables in the
data set so i use the shorthand notation
of the tilde
followed by the the period here the data
is the training set
and then for method we specify rf where
rf
stands for random forest now if we call
this thing that we just trained
there's a lot of helpful summary
information that gets outputted
so for instance we have 700 samples that
is 700 rows
20 predictors that is 20 columns two
classes
bad and good and now it says no
pre-processing here
because we didn't do the pre-processing
directly in the train function
so that's a little bit misleading
because we did pre-process
uh for resampling it used bootstrapping
and then you've got the resampling
results across tuning parameters
so in the resampling results we have
different values for the m tri
parameter and then on average how is the
accuracy
and how is the kappa metric so kappa is
actually typically a better choice to
use for our metric for selecting the
optimal model when we have class
imbalance
but by default the train function is
going to use the accuracy metric for
selecting the optimal
model and we see that on average
when m tri was 11 the accuracy was
0.7195
that's the highest accuracy across these
different values of
m tri and so that's the final value that
this model object is going to use
is m tri equals 11. so we're going to
see how this thing actually did
but first for this one iteration
of this model we're going to look at the
variable importance
now as i discussed when we were talking
about recursive feature elimination
random forest is one of several methods
that you can train using carrot
that provide an inherent mechanism for
ranking our variables from most to least
important so all we have to do is create
a variable importance object
using this uh function ver imp obviously
that stands for variable importance
create that object and then we're just
going to create a plot of that
i give it a title here german credit
variable importance
in parentheses random forest and then we
have a plot
of the most to least important variables
with amount
and age and employment duration sticking
at the top here
now you want to be really cautious with
interpreting these things with random
forest
and i have a whole video uh titled when
should you use random forests which has
a lengthy discussion on this
i can't get into all that here out of an
interest of time
uh but at least you know now how you go
about creating a variable importance
plot
because just as a gut check or common
sense kind of thing that you can do and
share with people
in terms of things that make sense
variable importance is a great thing to
report
so the last thing that we're going to do
in this video is
we're going to use that model that we've
trained to generate predictions for our
testing set
okay all we have to do is use the
predict function
where the first argument is that model
that we've trained
and the second argument is our testing
set
now the output of this function is just
going to be a vector
of the predicted classes so it goes bad
good
good good good good good bad good and
we're going to see later in this
tutorial series
we can generate our output to be
probabilities instead
but the simplest way and the default way
to do this
is just to output the predicted classes
the best way to summarize how we did
is via the confusion matrix function
so the key arguments here are reference
and data
reference is going to provide us the
true class values
obviously that just comes from the class
variable from the test set
and then the predicted values we just
generated those
we stored them in this fitted vector so
we're going to pass that to the data
argument
and then you're going to want to specify
the positive class
the positive class is just good
so we're going to run that and we get
all this amazing looking output here
in the next video we're going to step
through how you interpret the most
important pieces of this
output then we're going to be a little
bit more deliberate about how we tune
the hyper parameters as we train our
model
so i'll leave you all there thanks for
watching this video
if you enjoyed it consider sharing it
hit the like button
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data